les saisons précédentes dans mafiosa je
m'appelle sandra sandra paoli
à la mort de mon père françois paoli
chef d'un des plus puissants clans de
lille c'est moi jeune avocate qui
héritait d affaires j'avais trop peur
parce que ça soit tu seras j'ai mon
frère jean michel a accepté d'être le
second au début
depuis ce jour rien n'a plus été pareil
entre nous deux ce qui t'arrive pas au
jeu ça me faire payer quoi c'est dû
m'imposer par tous les moyens
une femme chef de clan c'est comme les
pédérastes c'est contre nature
la vengeance les règlements de comptes
font partie de notre vie
au début j'ai cru qu'on pourrait s'en
sortir
on a travaillé main dans la main avec
jean-michel pour nous pour ces enfants
carmen et matteo et avec ma garde
rapprochée thoniers manu une grande
famille les hommes qui travaillent pour
nous sont là parce qu'ils ont peur peur
de toi et paoli et puis jean michel a
voulu faire son chemin seul tu vas
souffrir l'instant dehors de mes
affaires
les guerres fratricides a commencé tu es
mort pour ta fille
il a été jusqu'à commandité ma mort mais
il a craqué il s'interposait a pris la
balle qui lui étaient destinées
à sa sortie comme un on attendait de
reformer la famille de retrouvailles en
somme la conclusion quand les records
c'est devenu irrespirable à cause et
nationalistes entrer dans la ronde jean
michel m'a vivement encouragés à quitter
bastia sa loyauté était un leurre pour
mieux me doubler je n'avais plus qu'une
idée en tête l'éliminer
j'ai tué mon frère et j'ai sombré
tony et manu ont pris leurs distances
ils ont voulu aussi voler de leurs
propres ailes
ils ont monté un piège pour me tuer
donner un choix
heureusement pour moi manu et cardiaques
la police m'a arrêté pour le meurtre de
jean michel carmen m'a vu baisser les
yeux
elle aussi est une parole
maintenant je suis seul santoni et manu
avec les nationalistes en embuscade et
flic qui s'agitent et carmen qui fait
l'événement a lieu elle c'est ma fille
aux arts l'ultime saison inédite
lundi 14 avril à 20h55 sur canal +